these days releasing a superhero movie
is a surefire way to make a billion
dollars
but over the years many have tried and
failed to add to the ever-growing roster
of comic book flicks
these are the most over-hyped superhero
movies that
never actually happened the 21st century
superhero film craze began in earnest in
2002
with sam raimi's spider-man which
starred toby maguire as the masked
web spinning crime fighter when raimi's
first spider venture raked in an
american box office take of 403 million
dollars
spider-man 2 became pretty much
inevitable that movie did just as well
when it was released in 2004 too and so
sony naturally followed it up with 2007
spider-man 3
a movie best known for this
how's the pie so good
despite attracting so-so reviews the
third movie still earned more money than
both its predecessors meaning sony was
more than justified in green lighting
spider-man 4
and spider-man 5. veteran actors john
malkovich and anne hathaway were both
attached to the franchise
and were to appear as villain vulture
and love interest felicia hardy
respectively and the crew was supposed
to start filming the fourth movie in
early 2010
but in january 2010 just before cameras
were set to roll
deadline reported that raymie had walked
away from the franchise having
reportedly insisted that a year wasn't
enough time to make a good enough movie
rather than looking for a replacement
sony canceled spider-man 4 altogether
opting instead to reboot the series with
the new cast and crew
sony successfully started their spider
franchise anew with 2012's the amazing
spider-man starring andrew garfield as
the world's favorite
spider bite victim the movie made a
hugely impressive 757 million dollars at
the worldwide box office
spurring the release of a sequel in
2014. shortly after the amazing
spider-man 2 hit theaters sony announced
its
next big steps into the spiderverse at
san diego comic con
november 2016 would see the release of a
sinister six movie debuting the
villainous super team on screen for the
very first
time consequently the previously
announced amazing spider-man 3 was
pushed from june 2016 to a 2018 release
date
but the future of both movies was thrown
into chaos when sony struck a deal with
marvel studios in 2015 allowing
spider-man to finally appear in the
marvel cinematic universe
you got hard kid where you from
queens brooklyn
the sony marvel co-production spider-man
homecoming hit theaters in 2017
rebooting the franchise yet again with
tom holland in the starring role
the character has only featured in mcu
films since then while sony has gone on
to develop its own villain-based
spidey universe the superman film
franchise lay dormant for years after
the thundering flop that was 1987
superman 4 the quest for peace that
movie earned a genuinely insulting 15
million dollars at the box office which
was
just less than its already modest 17
million budget but
in 1996 after tim burton's batman movies
had reinvigorated the superhero movie
genre warner brothers
john peters brought in filmmaker kevin
smith to carry on superman's story
smith was supposed to rewrite the
screenplay then titled
superman reborn which was subsequently
renamed superman lives
but peters had some bizarre demands for
smith for example
superman wasn't allowed to fly in the
movie and he also had to wear an all
black suit
there were also a number of polar bear
bodyguards involved for
some reason and at one point supes had
to fight a giant mechanical spider
smith somehow incorporated all these
requirements into a script and even
recommended that his frequent
collaborator ben
affleck play superman tim burton was
hired to direct however and he brought
in his own choice to wear the cape
nicholas cage months of rewrites delays
studio maneuvering and budgetary issues
ensued with superman lives
finally kicking the bucket when burton
stepped down to film sleepy hollow
instead
the franchise was thrown back into limbo
and call wouldn't reappear on the silver
screen until the release of superman
returns in 2006.
fox churned out a couple of fantastic
four movies back in the 2000's
the appropriately named the fantastic
four and its follow-up
rise of the silver surfer since that
second film made significantly less
money than the first
fox didn't go for the full trilogy but
the studio certainly wasn't done with
the characters
the studio hired green lantern co-writer
michael green to pan a reboot but three
years later the movie was still stuck in
development hell
so fox brought in jeremy slater to write
and hire josh trank to direct
but shooting on fantastic four was a
straight-up disaster with trank alleging
multiple instances of executive meddling
he later told polygon that his creative
input was often ignored
and that fox brought in new writers for
reshoots which the studio had allegedly
planned from the outset
scenes that trank wanted to film wound
up cut from the script while
other fully completed scenes were left
out of the movie's theatrical cut
the summer 2015 released fantastic four
didn't exactly
please the fans earning just 56.1
million dollars in north america and
amassing an atrocious
nine percent on rotten tomatoes it's
fantastic
say that again in the wake of that
cinematic debacle
fox removes their plan fantastic four
sequel from its 2017 release schedule
and now that marvel studios are
producing their own fantastic four movie
you can probably safely bet that this
particular version of marvel's first
family is dead
and buried superhero team at movies are
commonplace nowadays what with marvel's
hugely successful avengers movies and dc
comics slightly less successful justice
league
but that whole phenomenon might have
begun far earlier if warner brothers had
seen justice league mortal to its
completion
production on this superstar superhero
movie began in 2007 with the target
release date of 2009
george miller the filmmaker behind mad
max fury road
agreed to direct sets were built and a
cast was hired and fitted for costumes
army hammer was to star as batman dj
catrona was going to play superman megan
gayle would be wonder woman
common came on his green lantern and
adam brody was cast as the flash
warner brothers earmarked an astounding
200 million dollars for justice league
mortal
which would have ranked it among the
most costly films of all time
unfortunately the script still needed a
good amount of work and any potential
rewrites were delayed by the writers
guild of america strike in 2007 and
2008.
by the time that had been resolved most
of the cast members contracts had
expired
and they'd long moved on to other
projects
movie audiences were introduced to the
x-force in 2018's deadpool 2 in which
the iconic super squad was
personally assembled by the merc with
the mouth himself unfortunately
it doesn't end well oh yeah that's right
[Applause]
the x-force has been around in the
comics in various forms since the early
90s
conceived as a spin-off of the x-men
suitably plans for a now abandoned
x-force trilogy were set in motion
long before the deadpool films were
released in 2013 fox hired kick-ass 2
filmmaker jeff wadlow to write and
direct an x-force movie
he later teased the project's premise to
comic book movies saying
if x-men was about mutants who get to go
to private school with wolverine and
professor x
what about the mutants that have to go
to public school what about the ones who
don't have the benefactor looking out
for them
wadlow apparently developed a story that
would unfold over three movies following
a band of kids who eventually form a hit
squad and black ops team
now that disney has acquired fox however
it seems the chances of an x-force movie
happening anytime
soon have flown straight into the wood
chipper
after the x-men and the avengers it
seemed like the next big thing in the
world of marvel was destined to be the
inhumans
the studio wedded the public's appetite
for the lesser-known team of x-men like
individuals
first by introducing them to the mcu on
abc's popular series
agents of shield and then by announcing
plans to spin them off into their own
movie
at a marvel media event in 2014 studio
boss kevin feige said that inhumans
would mark the 20th mcu entry
comprising a huge part of the studio's
phase 3 slate of films
it was due to hit theaters on november
2nd 2018 then it was suddenly delayed
until summer 2019
and then marvel delayed the project
indefinitely the reason
well when marvel made a deal with sony
to include peter parker in the mcu the
studio pivoted its attention towards
their burgeoning spider-man franchise
considering the inhumans were second
tier at best compared to spidey the
project was quickly shelved in his place
and eventually turned into a widely
penned and
quickly cancelled abc television series
long before marvel comics realized it
could make its own movies in-house the
publisher would contract with various
different movie studios to bring its
most popular superheroes to life on the
big screen
while fox wound up with the rights to
the x-men and its assorted characters
for example
universal pictures got the rights to
make an incredible hulk movie production
on hulk began in 2002
starring australian actor eric bana as
the brilliant but troubled scientist
bruce banner
and it was all under the direction of
the acclaimed and award-winning
filmmaker ang lee
marvel was so optimistic that hulk would
be a hit that it contracted with
universal to make
a couple more marvel movies marvel
studios ceo aviarad
said at the time universal pictures has
proven to us that it has the vision
and creativity to bring our superheroes
to the big screen
in grand fashion he subsequently
announced an upcoming epic underwater
tale of majestic fantasy
no not that one this film was actually
submariner a story about the aquatic
anti-hero and classic marvel character
namor
screenwriter david self best known at
the time for road to perdition was
attached to rig the screenplay
apparently the story was to follow the
protector of atlantis as he discovers
his deep sea powers and wages war
against the evil crane
submariner failed to come up for air
however and after the project bounced
between a number of other filmmakers the
rights to the character eventually
reverted back to marvel
as of right now the character has yet to
make his silver screen debut
at the same time that a hulk-inspired
contracting frenzy led marvel to ink
their deal with universal
the two entertainment behemoths
announced another movie based on prime
a relatively obscure comic book
character dating back to the early 1990s
javier odd announced at the time prime
is a complete
departure from the standard superhero
story with this film we are developing
what we think
will be marvel's first superhero action
comedy
marvel big shots kevin feige and stan
lee were cited as executive producers
while erod was set to actively produce
the film
it was supposed to tell an extremely
shazam-like tale of a teenager who
as the result of a government experiment
could instantly turn into an adult who's
also
a superhero screenwriting duo don
callame and chris conroy were
responsible for the script even though
they had just won feature film credit
between them the 2001 disney channel
original
movie founded seeing as how no progress
has been made on this film in nearly
two decades it's probably fair to say
that the time for prime has passed
in late 2018 deadline reported that fox
had hired julius avery
director of the horror movie overlord to
helm a new
big budget film version of flash gordon
a popular comic strip in the early 20th
century it centered on the exploits of
muscular american athlete flash gordon
who heads into space to fight the evil
ming the merciless
the last time it appeared on the big
screen was as a campy low budget movie
in 1980
starring sam jay jones as flash and
featuring an iconic soundtrack by queen
gordon's alive after kingsman filmmaker
matthew vaughn opted to produce but not
direct the movie fox accepted a story
pitch from avery who is a lifelong fan
of the flash gordon comic strip
that version of the movie ultimately
fell apart but shortly after disney
acquired fox in 2019
thor ragnarok director taiko atiti was
announced as the new director of the
long gestating flash gordon revival
which had apparently been reworked as an
animated feature
not more than a few weeks later however
flash gordon appeared on a long list of
projects in various states of
pre-production that disney had inherited
from
fox and which the mouse house had
summarily canceled
ming isn't the only merciless one it
would seem
for decades now sony has controlled all
of spider-man's
many villains and supporting characters
and a few years ago the studio decided
to tell their stories as part of a
shared universe now officially titled
the sony pictures universe of marvel's
characters this wide-ranging franchise
includes every spider-verse movie that
isn't specifically centered on
spider-man such as the tom hardy vehicle
venom
and its sequel as well as morbius
starring jared leto as the titular
living vampire sony also planned a
team-up movie featuring two other
spider-man characters the mercenary
silver sable and the ace cat burglar
black cat
in may 2017 sony tapped gina prints by
the wood to direct silver and black with
plans for a theatrical release date of
february 2019.
that all changed in june 2018 however
when sony took the movie off of its
schedule
there were apparently internal problems
with the productions specifically that
prince by the wood reportedly didn't
much care for the shooting script she'd
been given
continuous delays over the script meant
that meeting a theatrical release eight
months later would have been next to
impossible however it wasn't long after
scrapping silver and black that sony
decided it would instead pursue separate
movies for the two characters both of
which are currently in development
for now james franco is an artist with
many passions from writing to directing
to painting and he isn't above showing
up in the odd superhero movie either
early in his acting career he played
harry osborn in sam raimi's 2000's
spider-man trilogy
not only that he also nearly became one
of the few actors to play more than one
comic book character in different
franchises
having been attached to star as the
mutant multiple man in a stand-alone
film for fox
in 2017 deadline reported that the man
of multiple talents would produce and
star in a film about the mutant
james madrox who is able to create
clones of himself at will
franco told the hollywood reporter in
2017 that he wanted to make a different
edgier comic book movie akin to deadpool
or logan he said
our bottom line mo is how can we push
this into new ground
we're going to take this superhero thing
and push it into a new genre
x-men franchise overseer simon kinberg
was also actively involved in the
project
and nearly a year after its announcement
he told ign that a script was currently
being worked on
that of course was in 2018 and with
disney having acquired fox soon after
it's definitely not looking good for
multiple men
[Music]
there are three things that almost
everyone can agree are fantastic
cowboys ninjas and vikings
most film goers are also of the
consensus that chris pratt is
awesome as the likable actor is
headlined blockbusters as desperate as
jurassic world guardians of the galaxy
and the lego movie
hollywood producers searching for a
surefire hit didn't have to think too
hard then to combine cowboys ninjas
vikings and chris pratt
via the movie cowboy ninja viking based
on the graphic novel of the same name by
aj lieberman and riley rossmo
the film was to depict the mind-blowing
adventures of dr sebastian gillane a
psychotherapist who can transform into
three different
secret agent personas a cowboy a ninja
and a viking
pratt signed on to stars dr galain with
priyanka chopra featuring in a
supporting role
game of thrones director michelle
mclaren would make her feature film
debut with a 65 million dollar budget to
play with
this fun action comedy was scheduled to
hit movie theaters on june 28
2019 but just a week after chopra's
involvement was announced
universal pulled the movie from its
schedule and ended production delaying
the film
indefinitely according to an insider the
film had a number of script issues still
to work out
its problems were apparently so bad in
fact that rumors universal would cancel
the movie had floated around for nearly
half a year
before the studio finally called it a
day
over the course of the last two decades
the x-men series has been one of
hollywood's most
lucrative and expansive franchises the
dozen plus films in the series raked in
more than six
billion dollars altogether and vox
explored all kinds of offshoots and
sub-franchises such as
hugh jackman's wolverine standalones
these included the
instant classic logan the less beloved
the wolverine
and the much derided x-men origins
wolverine
the studio also toyed with other origins
movies however such as one about the
rise of the super villain magneto which
was later reworked into the tema prequel
x-men first class
they also considered a film about remy
lebeau otherwise known as gambit
the louisiana-born mutant with a thing
for explosive playing cards
gambit has made a few appearances in
x-men related media over the years
he was a main character on fox's 1990s
x-men animated series
and he showed up for a cameo in x-men
origins wolverine
when announcing a solo gambit film
however fox ignored taylor kitsch who
played the character in that film in
favor of 21 jump street and gi joe star
channing tatum
a succession of high-profile directors
circled the movie including the born
identities doug lyman
and pirates of the caribbean score
verbinski somehow though fox just
couldn't get this movie off the ground
and the studio delayed its release once
or twice in 2019
before settling on march 2020 after
disney acquired fox the house of mouse
quietly canceled the movie
finally consigning it to the ash heap of
hollywood history
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Applause]
[Music]